you guys wanted the money especially
with the Chris Weidman incident I saw it
I thought the legalese for the joke
well it's horribly ugly odda here's two
reasons why it's hard for Mowgli Dada
first of all he's a giant like you have
to understand Dan Mowgli odd is like six
foot five 300 pounds he's a huge man
I mean he's [ __ ] huge he cowers over
most of the fighters and so he's above
these guys and if Mousasi is pinning
down
Weidman so he's got him in a headlock
right he's pulling him down these mean
them in the face like he was thinking
how tall my Riata is in the first place
right like this now think he's looking
down if these guys knew each other in
the head he's got to stay close by in
case something happens there's no way he
could see those hands from where he was
standing so he took a educated guess
based on as many many years of
refereeing that both hands were down and
it was so close is that you would have
to be on the other side of the Ring
looking at the ground to know whether or
not it was touching if you're above it
the weimar Glee ottawa's how could he
know he really couldn't know and it's
not his fault
he's an excellent referees volved is
that the the athletic commission under
situations like this doesn't use an
instant replay and they should because
it's the fair thing to do to make sure
that the fight is it's fair and I think
Weidman could have gone on I think had
there been a question whether or not it
was legal they could look at the instant
replay and then they make the call the
the strikes are legal we're going to
continue and you either continue them
from the exact same position and say
ready go or you have a protocol in place
like you have to separate them go back
two corners and reengage which is bad
for Mousasi because Mousasi had him in a
good position it was landing strikes so
it's impossible for Dan Majerle odda
to to be absolutely certain from where
he was standing as big as he is looking
down like that I would just imagine it
probably looked like wide men's hands
were touching when we saw it in the
replay I asked them to show me different
angle angles yes I'm like because of the
first they said look it looks like it's
illegal then I said I don't see his
fingers I want to see his fingers let me
see his fingers and then when we went to
one where you see his fingers you can
see Mousasi lifts him up which is
what you're supposed to do so the only
reason why Weidman had his hands down
like that is because he thought that
could prevent him from getting hit he
didn't have his hands down like that
because it's an offensive gesture he's
not like putting his hands down there
just because it's a next move you know
what he's doing is he's dealing with the
fact that Mousasi has his neck he's
dealing with the fact he's getting kneed
in the head and he's thinking the best
way to stop did to put my two hands down
because like that's not a position that
you would ever be in if you were trying
to hurt somebody right so what he's
trying to do is trying to stop the knees
or figure out what to do and catches his
mind because he's been tagged a few
times since Riley got hurt and those two
needs hit him hard and then the referee
tells him it's an illegal mean so he's
like okay when we take this time to take
a break I deserve it I got hit with an
illegal knee so in his eyes he's doing
what you're supposed to do if somebody
fouls you in his eyes I got fouled he
doesn't know he could hit with too
[ __ ] hard knees right they tell him
it was illegal he thinks it's illegal so
he goes on about it like it's illegal so
he sits down then the doctors come over
and examine him and then they someone
tells him I believe is John McCarthy
tells Danberg leotta that it was a legal
knee he was like it was legal I just
watch the replay he shows it to Dan
there's nothing again can do now we've
showed the replay over and over now to
the to the people that were watching on
pay-per-view
and we're like they're illegal these
means are legal this is just a mistake
and so then they don't know what to do
they don't really have a protocol on
place so they stop the fight and they
give a TKO victory to K go to insanity
which is crazy because Dan was in no way
going to stop the fight right there like
it wasn't like Weidman was getting hit
so hard he was right about to stop it
and then they said oh closely these are
illegal they weren't illegal but I was
going to stop it anyway so let's stop
the fight it's not that no it's the
fight was going on and it was stopped
just because of a mistake a mistake by
the Commission that they didn't
understood they didn't have a good
protocol in place to start a fight up
and they don't have a protocol in place
to check in as to replay under really
really difficult to discern violations
like this because it's really hard for
me a professional commentator who's
right next to the cage I'm right there
dude I'm touching the floor where the
cage is on and I can't figure out if
it's legal or not I have to watch the
replay so Dan in the heat of the moment
I'm
he's watching to the best 185 pounds in
the world right Gengar Musashi's tagging
Weidman wyman keeps taking him down
it's a [ __ ] battle mad about it's a
battle between two world-class fighters
and Wyman's down hard he could have come
back from that he's taking those hard
knees who knows we would have done he
might have pulled guard and pulled
Mousasi on top of them and got the sweep
and the round goes up look what just
happened with Darren Elkins and in and
that that crazy comeback that he had did
you see that fight oh man Jesus Christ I
bet dick who's his [ __ ] super
high-level up and coming down for this
Regas now this was like to see - oh yeah
I saw that one yeah he took the beaten
to death of his life for the third round
he knocks the guy out and it was the
woods world erupted by a place over
there's a guy like Weidman is just like
a guy like Darren Elkins he can come
back from the dead you might stop him
I mean Darren Elkins bestop Chad Mendes
[ __ ] him up but he might [ __ ] you up
in the third round - so you got to give
a champion like wide been the benefit of
the doubt so the problem I don't believe
that it was Dan Burghley on his fault I
think Dan thought he was doing the right
thing and his his mindset is to protect
the fighters at all times if it's an
illegal knee he's got a step and I just
think it was so close it was hard to
tell and then in the heat of this
exchange it's all crazy and it's a very
high-level fight it's super important
and it's in New York and so the one the
Commission didn't know what the [ __ ] to
do that's when it became a problem
that's when almost I wish somebody was
there that what I would have done I
would have said don't stop the fight
because the fight wasn't going to be
stopped with to restart the fight from
the position that it's in right there
where you going oh he needs a man so I
wouldn't stop the fight it wasn't his it
wasn't that decision to stop the fight
it was the commissioners decision I'm
pretty sure and I think it was just
because they didn't know what else to do
I think they just didn't know they
didn't have a thing to do in place it's
hard it takes a while to figure out how
to correctly
referee and judge and officiate in a in
a state athletic commission that hasn't
had mixed martial arts before and also
they have it so you don't have a lot of
expense or experience referees the
referees are gonna have to come from
other places guys like Big John or Dan
ergh leotta and then the commission
unfortunately even though the referees
were in place there were really
high-level there's a commission that's
really not used to doing this it's not
their fault they just did this don't
have the experience Nevada State has it
down
California has it down Andy Foster in
California he might be the best guy in
the business